in Batman the war of jokes and riddles
comes to a damning conclusion for the
Dark Knight and Catwoman will decide
whether she can accept Bruce's marriage
proposal
we've got writer Tom King here to set
the stage for the grand finale in issue
32 this is the biggest moments that I've
ever written in a comic book because if
you've been reading Batman in Batman 24
Batman got underneath poured his heart
out said you know with a diamond from
the first day they met and said marry me
and then Catwoman didn't give an answer
it's a big matzo ball to have hanging
out there yeah
and here it is we're an issue 32 and the
answer comes that's what she's gonna say
yes or no and it's all based on you've
seen sort of the end of the war now and
now you're gonna see the confession what
Batman did cuz Batman did something that
he knows if he's gonna marry someone if
they're gonna say yes then he has to
confess it the reason he loves
Catwoman's because he sees her
vulnerabilities and he wants her to see
his vulnerabilities that's how they find
their true love and he's like this is
the this is the part of me that's the
softest this is the part of me that that
I need the most help with you got a rip
reveal those tender meaty vents before
you marry somebody that's what famine is
all about with face-punching
right it's those tender bites that
philosophy swell so faces get pretty
tender after you punch them okay
how does Catwoman react after she hears
the food I think for the she is not
someone easily shocked she has seen
everything the world has that can throw
at you she's been as low as you can be
in as high as you can be so I think she
thinks oh it's just another confession I
get it you did something bad or you know
whatever I've you know I'm a neat I've
been evil I've been good but this is the
first time since she was a child that
she's actually genuinely surprised where
she's like I did not think that was you
I mean it and it's an honest question to
where it's not easy it's not like oh
okay I get it you had a problem will
over coming together it's something when
she's like this will affect the rest of
our relationship together you're not the
man I thought you were
but are you still the man that I want to
spend the light my life with where did
the issue go after issue 32 where does
it go
so once the answer is given we turn that
answer into the next epoch and it's a
it's a story that's called a dream of me
and it's a Batman leaves Goffin on
Gotham on an epic quest and meanwhile
the Robins sort of all find out that
he's done this proposal dealing with
that proposal at that moment is gonna be
how does dick deal with his best friend
doing it without telling him how does
Jason do he's always the rebel he's the
one who always just says don't do
something straight like that's bad what
are you doing
how does Damian Damon is a crazy person
whose mother is different to been
Catwoman how does he deal with that so
that's all that the next arc is about
that they don't know how to take this
and in this quest becomes an illegal
thing that becomes the Robins against
Batman and it's in the desert and it's
sweaty it's wonderful that's a sneak
peek at Batman 32 and here's a complete
rundown of the new DC books hitting
stores this week
[Music]
[Music]
that's the news for now but we are
heading to New York later this week to
catch all the surprises coming out of
Comic Con so make sure you keep up with
our live coverage every day from Friday
to Sunday 3:00 to 5:00 p.m. Eastern Time
on both YouTube and the DC Comics
Facebook page see you next time